[Musique]
et c'est déjà sa dernière chronique
sport de l'année bonsoir nickel et demi
d'euros et oui le temps passe vite
le temps passe vite alors pour ceux qui
n'ont pas suivi nos petits rendez vous
depuis le début de la saison chaque
lundi vous venez sur ce plateau pour
présenter lé principaux résultats du
week-end vous nous emmenez ou pour
commencer alors direction trappe
aujourd'hui un peu moins de 20 minutes
de nos studios ce dimanche 16 décembre
en match en retard du championnat de
régionale 3 les trappistes se sont
imposés dans des conditions climatiques
difficiles à domicile contre rueil
malmaison score final 1 à 0 un score qui
suffit à leur bonheur on écoute
l'entraîneur de l'équipe
hicham lazaar dit au micro de notre
journaliste nicolas dans des sentiments
de victoire logique et méritée
comme si on aurait pu se rendre le match
beaucoup plus facile on n'a pas su
concrétiser nos temps forts on a une
équipe de relais qui nous a pas mal
embêter on a su faire le dos rond on n'a
pas su profiter des espaces qui nous
offrait
par rapport au rapport de force mais la
finalité c'est que on a su être solides
ne pas prendre de but et qu'on termine
meilleure défense du championnat
alors c'est mickaël c'est important de
gagner mais est-ce que elle revêt une
importance particulière cette victoire
de trappes pour lui évidemment vous le
savez bien en tout cas chaque match
compte et en particulier celui là avec
cette victoire les trappistes reste
invaincu et reprennent la première place
de la poule c de régionale 3 avec un
petit point d'avancé sur boulogne
billancourt le podium l'objectif fixé en
début de saison semble de plus en plus
accessible l'objectif est toujours le
même on est des compétiteurs et même si
normal que le président ils soient
tranquilles ils modèrent il tempère les
joueurs nous on n'a qu'un objectif c'est
de sets gagnés de gagner de gagner tous
les week-ends et de rendre à la fois le
staff tous les gens autour les
supporters qui viennent nombreux fiers
de nous et voilà c'est la première place
à l'est aussi pour eux en 2019 les
trappistes tenteront de garder cette
dynamique après la trêve hivernale pour
conserver la première place et jordi
shams et redit se rendront sur le
terrain des mureaux le dimanche 20
janvier et oui ça fait tard leur
résolution prolonger leur série
d'invincibilité qui affiche actuellement
dix matches sans défaite du rugby à
présent dans quelle direction le
championnat d'honneur je peux rien vous
cacher à grégory dimanche dans la blinde
un plan b à versailles n'en finit plus
de gagner comme trappe en football les
versailles et sont toujours invaincus
leurs victimes du jour le skiff les
joueurs de la cité royale on va il
balayé cette équipe sur le score de 40 à
3 avec cette victoire les bleus
conservent la première place avec 42
points huit de plus que leur dauphin
montesson leur bilan est parfait avant
la trêve 9 victoires en 9 matches
disputés siens on continue à parler du
championnat honneur mais cette fois-ci
de la poule 2 le sky rugby a sorti un
gros match ce week-end en s'imposant à
domicile contre ministère finance sur le
score de 34 à 11 de son côté cheuvreux
s'impose 11 à 7 à l'extérieur face à
vitry au classement les saint quentinois
conserve la sixième place du championnat
avec 20 points et chevreuse est deuxième
avec 32 points en neuf journées
merci michael on vous retrouve dans
votre émission aux études sport je vois
que vous êtes venus d'ailleurs avec un
trophée en plateau c'est pas pour moi
une petite coupe non c'est pas pour voir
désolé